a classic garageband Russian style
and a garage upholstery shop and a
do-it-yourself recycling center they're
all part of Granada a garage cooperative
in the City of Napa rish nya chimney a
city of half a million people over a
thousand kilometers east of Moscow many
of the city's male population get
together here this is where they earn
their living often with manual trades
and almost always off the books Jenner's
my customers are all Russians my price
is a reasonable you're quick I don't
think I need any paintings here I'll
stay here till someone throws me out
anybody do this what's karthi everybody
comes here with their problems this is a
world of its own with its own laws what
mr. this male domain is ruled by a woman
Yekaterina Yerima cova known locally as
Catherine the Great yeah yeah I know my
lads and they know me Monsieur merkava
has been chairwoman of the garage
cooperative for the past 20 years she
can open a few doors that would
otherwise stay locked tight to outsiders
not a mine in this workshop old Soviet
cars are made good as new customization
goes hand in hand with restoration these
are collectors items on four wheels but
Yeti as will call him is a master
mechanic in high demand a customer
explains what he'd like done with his
old was aqui your Prime Mr pushy
wonderful doing well yeah he rents two
garages and employs and assistant
extreme all the diet's Lenny the
customer prefers exotic models this one
for instance is slow but safe he's come
to us because he appreciates comfort
above appearances would you and because
nobody but us can do the things he wants
doing
at least not at the prices we offer but
Yeti is versatile in his garage basement
he does upholstery work of all kinds he
says he's legally registered as a small
businessman as legal as he can be
working cash in hand and no billing that
may be why he wanted to remain anonymous
mm-hmm sure you as I don't need anything
else even if I end up having to sew
slippers one day when i get to be an old
fart somebody will always buy them or at
least give me a bottle of milk for them
so i can survive well I go for me yeah I
thought it's not most of the other
renters or owners of the over 2,000
units in Granada think and live much the
same way garage cooperatives like this
one are a holdover from the Soviet era
they were built to house vehicles but
since capitalism took hold the state has
not been privy to what goes on behind
the closed doors
the chairwoman can't or won't say how
many of the members have registered
their trades with the authorities but
she doesn't seem that surprised that
most are working off the books and not
paying taxes even if one of them
suddenly decided to go legit and
register his trade he'd have to pay so
much more in rent and taxes and undergo
so many checks from environmental to
fire safety regulations that his
business wouldn't survive if so what the
quick that's why everyone here lies low
like worth the money you see yet
estimates of the garage Nikki's numbers
run to 30 million or about forty percent
of Russia's able-bodied population a
vast shadow economy they have no
intention of sharing their earnings with
the state yet they're urgently needed by
Russia's legitimate economy by the
industry they once fled buddies used to
work as an automotive mechanic now he's
specialized in fixing loudspeakers for
30 years I worked in a plant and hardly
got any pay for it finally I quit and
I've been my own boss here ever since
not officially of course I avoid any
contact with the authorities they're
corrupt themselves they just demand
primes I won't go along with that but
I'm I've years I've done little to me no
government has yet succeeded in breaking
the vicious circle the tradesmen cheat
the state or the state cheats them all
across Russia the situation is much the
same billions of rubles roll past the
state
what did possess bayit smooching not to
make his officials pay taxes first okay
if they'd pay taxes on their own
property then my boys would all be
working here legally President Vladimir
Putin has finally realized the urgency
of controlling unregistered businesses
and ordered an overhaul of the
incomprehensible and overly complicated
taxation and certification systems for
small businesses but that may not be
nearly enough to bring the shadow
economy into the open not as long as
Russians lack any real confidence in
their state